Shure:  全是空的
Shure:  楼上几瓶酒也是我放的
Shure: the few bottles of wine upstairs are mine too.
Jake: 就是咱就不要做意大利面了
Jake: So, let's not make pasta.
Jake: 哈哈哈有没有这个
Jake: Hahaha, do we have this?
Lucia: 我也会
Tasha: 这个活动大家应该都会吗
Tasha: 有没有这个活动吗
Tasha: Do we have this activity?
Jake: 有有做饭的活动
Jake: Yes, we have cooking activities.
Jake: 没有做意大利面的活动
Jake: But no pasta-making activities.
Alice:你们喜欢酸汤麻辣菜吗
Alice: 不知道够不够
Alice: Not sure if it's enough.
Alice: 买几个吧
Alice: Let's buy a few.
Katrina:  让我写上
Alice:我写吧
Alice: I'll write it.
Jake: 这是什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Tasha: 你猜打嗯
Tasha: Guess.
Jake: 打面糊
Tasha: 差不多吧
Tasha: 可以
Shure: 打鸡蛋的那个
Tasha: 啊对
Jake: 鸡蛋是吧
Jake: Eggs, huh?
Shure:  就那个呜呜呜
Jake: 鸡蛋我看怎么会多一些
Jake: Looks like there will be more eggs.
Shure: 不不不不
Jake: 一口
Jake: One bite
Shure: 但是看了是是这个是这个机器吗
Jake:哦
Shure:  对
Shure: 然后这么装上去
Jake:哦
Shure:  然后一按他就两个一起打
Alice: 就是一个汤嘛
Alice: It's just a soup, right?
Shure:  打蛋清用的
Lucia: 咱们这里要买美分纸吗
Lucia: Do we need to buy masking tape here?
Jake: 你的描述
Jake: Your description
Jake: 然后最后会兑现成一个现成
Shure:  对让AI更了解我们人类
Shure: Yeah, make the AI understand us humans better.
Tasha: 我知道啊
Tasha: I know.
Tasha: 对哦画画的时候会用到
Tasha: Yes, you use it when drawing.
Lucia: 哦我以为是那
Lucia: Oh, I thought it was for that.
Lucia: 那种就是用来对对对
Lucia: 美缝
Tasha: 也可以再多买点别的水果
Tasha: We can also buy some more fruits.
Tasha: 装饰在巧蛋糕上
Tasha: To decorate the cake.
Lucia: 所以这个是那种
Lucia: So this is that kind
Lucia: 就是画布旁边贴的那个
Lucia: that's used to stick on the side of the canvas.
Tasha:  对对对
Tasha: 是画纸上面贴的胶
Tasha: It's the tape you stick on the drawing paper.
Lucia: 而且我每次贴都不知道他叫什么
Lucia: And I never know what it's called when I stick it.
Shure: J人字体不统一了
Tasha: 美文纸啊
Tasha: It's called masking tape.
Shure: 你不得统一一下
Lucia: 原来是我一直把它当成是一种跟胶带
Lucia: 类似的东西
Lucia: Something similar.
Tasha: 就是纸胶布嘛
Tasha: It's just paper tape.
Tasha: 对对对嗯
Tasha: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 然后就反正我看到是那个东西
Lucia: So whenever I see that thing,
Lucia: 我就知道是他了
Lucia: I just know it's that.
Lucia: 但我不知道他叫什么
Lucia: But I never know its name.
Katrina: 还蛮准的我觉得真的准
Tasha: 先放这吧好
Tasha: Let's put this here for now, okay?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 这两个规格不一样吗我感觉
Tasha: Aren't these two specs different? I feel like they are.
Katrina: 买点草莓再买点
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Tasha: 嗯不了不了不了算了
Tasha: Hmm, no, no, forget it.
Alice: 没在那求过姻缘从不求
Alice: I've never prayed for a relationship there, never.
Lucia: 这个是哪位宝宝的
Lucia: Whose baby is this?
Lucia: 好像也是某个电器的配件
Lucia: It seems to be a part of some appliance.
Tasha: 嗯这是送的
Tasha: Yeah, this was a freebie.
Tasha: 没有这个好用
Tasha: This one isn't as good.
Lucia: 啊那这个不是
Lucia: Ah, so this isn't needed.
Lucia: 反正不太需要是吧
Lucia: Not really needed, right?
Tasha: 啊
Lucia: OK OK
Lucia:  okay, okay.
Lucia: 我把外面那个箱子稍微收拾一下
Lucia: I'll tidy up the box outside a bit.
Lucia: 那些不需要的我就扔掉了
Lucia: I'll throw away the unnecessary stuff.
Lucia: 这个配件先撂这吧
Lucia: Let's leave this part here for now.
Lucia: 说不定能用上
Lucia: Maybe we'll need it later.
Lucia: 然后说明书齐了吗
Lucia: Are all the manuals there?
Lucia: 这个哎算了
Lucia: This, ah, never mind.
Tasha: 应该有一个电池吧
Tasha: There should be a battery, right?
Lucia: 对先放这 放在外面
Alice: 电池是不是在一个小对
Alice: The battery is in a small... right.
Tasha: 在一个袋子里哎
Tasha: In a bag, right?
Tasha: 那个袋子
Tasha: That bag.
Tasha: 嗯被扔掉了吗
Tasha: Was it thrown away?
Alice: 我记得刚才见到他了
Alice: I remember seeing it just now.
Tasha: 嗯哦垫子是吧是一个
Tasha: Hmm, oh, the mat, right? It's a...
Tasha: 对垫子
Alice:是一个泡沫
Alice: 那个那个有泡泡的那个
Tasha: 是的是那个袋子
Alice: 所以那个袋子去哪了
Alice: So where did that bag go?
Shure: 这是温针
Alice: 他长得很像垃圾
Alice: 会不会被误扔掉了
Shure:  有可能
Tasha: 他测的不准呀
Tasha: It's not accurate.
Tasha: 哈哈
Shure: 乐死了
Jake: 啊多少度
Tasha:  27度
Jake: 那不要死了
Tasha: 哈哈哈哦哦
Tasha: Hahaha, oh oh.
Tasha: 在上身
Tasha: On the upper body.
Alice: 他得有一个传递的过程
Alice: There has to be a transmission process.
Jake: 我的体感温度吧这就是
Lucia: 这个可以不要了
Lucia: We can get rid of this one.
Tasha: 好那他就是真的了
Tasha: Okay, then it's real.
Shure: 看着就脑袋疼
Lucia: 把那些比较软的
Lucia: Get those softer ones.
Lucia: 和不好看的箱子收拾收拾
Lucia: And the ugly boxes sorted out.
Lucia: 就可以扔掉了
Lucia: You can throw them away.
Lucia: 咱只留那种硬一点的
Lucia: Let's only keep the sturdier ones.
Shure: 硬的
Lucia: 对外观好看一点的就行
Lucia: And the ones that look nicer.
Tasha: 他里面原本有一颗垫子
Tasha: There was originally a cushion inside.
Tasha: 嗯那就够了
Tasha: Hmm, that's enough.
Tasha: 好辛苦长大了或许
Tasha: How hard it is to grow up.
Lucia: 有剪刀或者之类的东西吗
Tasha: 有剪刀
Tasha: 剪刀在
Tasha: The scissors are here.
Tasha: 这瓶水是我的吗
Tasha: Is this bottle of water mine?
Lucia: 呃应该是你的
Lucia: Uh, it should be yours.
Lucia: 这瓶水是我的
Lucia: This bottle is mine.
Tasha: 行可以拿笔在上面简单写一下
Tasha: Okay, you can write on it with a pen.
Lucia: 虽然有可能会被蹭掉
Lucia: Although it might rub off.
Shure:  可以拿白板笔写
Lucia: 不好意思 sorry
Tasha: 嗯你喝吗
Lucia: 便当啊这个
Lucia: This is for lunch.
Tasha: 我喝这个
Tasha: I'll drink this.
Alice: 你不是不喝饮料吗
Tasha: 这是我的
Tasha: This is mine.
Jake: 哦呵呵呵
Jake:嗯这是喝饮料啊嗯
Tasha: 杨老师洗到累吗
Jake:不累
Shure:  杨老师是Supersaya啊
Shure: Jake is a Super Saiyan.
Shure:  杨老师是超级赛亚人
Tasha: 赛亚人是什么意思
Tasha: What's a Saiyan?
Alice: 一种神奇的
Shure: 这种能在5:20睡觉
Shure: 5:20睡觉  13点14准时醒
Shure:  你这个9点准时醒有点反人类
Shure:  说实话哈哈哈哈
Shure: To be honest, hahaha.
Jake:那我是不是快醒了呀还是已经醒了
Lucia: 等一会吧
Lucia: Wait a bit.
Shure: 几点了
Shure: What time is it?
Jake:是不是应该弄个钟买个表
Shure: 买个表吧对
Tasha: 不知道他怎么放进去
Tasha: No idea how he got it in there.
Alice: 这下面有碗啊
Alice: There's a bowl underneath.
Tasha: 哦你说哦
Tasha: Oh, you mean, oh.
Alice: 烤箱啊我以为你说要打这个哎
Alice: The oven, I thought you meant to beat this.
Alice: 要不然把这个打完
Alice: Or we could beat this.
Alice: 你吃了
Alice: You eat it.
Tasha: 这个盘还没洗好
Tasha: This plate hasn't been washed yet.
Shure:  这个用微波炉
Shure: Use the microwave.
Shure:  打一下就行
Lucia: 不是这个
Lucia: 这些都是有用的是吧
Lucia: These are all useful, right?
Shure: 有盘吧放盘里
Lucia: 嗯对我把这些那个就是没有用的
Lucia: Yeah, I'll throw away the ones that aren't useful.
Jake:弄掉了
Tasha: 没关系没有洒出来就行
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 但是就是我觉得就留这种对完整一点的
Lucia: But I think we should keep the ones that are more intact.
Lucia: 就行像这种就他比较烂的
Lucia: Like the ones that are more damaged.
Lucia: 或者说特别软的这种感觉
Lucia: Or the ones that are really soft.
Lucia: 就可以不要了
Lucia: We can discard those.
Lucia: 这个其实可以先留一下
Lucia: We can keep this one for now.
Lucia: 万一我们有用到这种长的那个啥好了
Lucia: Just in case we need something long like this.
Tasha: 好了不用帮人家洗这么干净
Jake:好的
Jake:比划一下
Jake: 我这是自带的
Tasha: 昨晚的
Jake: I brought this from last night.
Shure:  不是昨天的
Shure: It's not from yesterday.
Shure:  晚上的吗
Shure:  咱过日子就要有过日子的样子
Shure: We should live like we mean it.
Jake:过日子的人是吧
Shure:  就是
Alice: 两分钟就行了
Jake: EGO life都是过日子的人
Tasha: 你猜这个是用来干嘛的
Tasha: Guess what this is for?
Shure: 这个火的大小这样就行
Jake:这这是架子吗
Jake: Is this a stand?
Shure:  然后开始这些
Shure: And then start with these.
Tasha: 就是啊他是用来插烤鸡的
Shure:  OK搞定
Lucia: 就这样吧
Lucia: Just like this.
Shure: 过日子过日子
Shure: Just living life.
Tasha: 对啊在烤箱里转
Tasha: Yeah, it rotates in the oven.
Jake:就这么转哦
Jake: It rotates like this, huh?
Lucia: 这些都就不要了
Lucia: Let's not use these.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh?
Tasha:再来
Tasha: Again.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Alright.
Jake:有人打我电话，原来是快递
Shure: 喂，你好
Shure: Hello, hi.
Jake:嗯好稍等哈
Lucia: 哦这个需要热一下吗对
Lucia: Oh, does this need to be heated?
Alice: 哎呀无所谓
Alice: Oh, it doesn't matter.
Lucia: 对我把手洗一下刚才收拾一下
Lucia: Yeah, let me wash my hands, I was just cleaning up.
Lucia: 那啥
Lucia: So...
Lucia: 这样如果需要弄弄盘子菜什么的
Lucia: This way, if we need to handle plates or food...
Lucia: 可以帮上忙
Lucia: We can help out.
Lucia: 要不然手太脏了
Lucia: Otherwise, our hands are too dirty.
Lucia: 这个要洗
Lucia: This needs to be washed.
Lucia: 这应该有纸我记得啊在这
Lucia: There should be paper here, I remember. Oh, here it is.
Shure:  我的小窝
Shure: My little place.
Jake: 来，大伙出去吃啊
Jake: Come on, everyone, let's go eat out.
Lucia: 啊在外边那个桌子那里吗
Katrina: 也可以啊
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 摘眼镜吗哥
Shure: Should I take off my glasses, bro?
Lucia: 同问
Lucia: Same here.
Jake:呃，这个把这个植物摆出来就结束好吧
Jake: Uh, let's just place this plant here and we're done, okay?
Shure: okok
Shure: Okay, okay.
Tasha: 哎呀
Tasha: Oh my.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh my.
Shure: 就是呀
Shure: Exactly.
Jake:哦你已经断掉了你已经没有电了应该
Jake:要不看一下
Shure:  有可能是那外面外面太亮了看不到那个白光
Shure: It might be too bright outside to see the white light.
Jake:没有我看到你了你看到我了吗
Jake:但是但是没关系
Katrina: 后面这一段也挺重要的
Jake:对对
Jake:这怎么玩呢可以撑高一点
Jake:看一下
Katrina: 11点09
Shure: 这桌子说实话有点太脏了
Lucia: 有没有抹布什么的我去拿一下
Shure: 或者咱们可以买点一次性桌布什么的
Shure: 在外面吃饭
Shure: 虽然不符合这个理念但是它很方便
Shure: 是吧
是的
Katrina: 哦是不是充电宝没连上充电宝不亮了
Shure: 它可能累了罢工了
Shure: 我发现我这个非常的稳定就从来没有出过事故
Katrina: 这旁边邻居都是干啥的都是民宿吗
Shure: 应该不全是
Katrina: 应该不是自己家的
Katrina: 好安静啊像那种乡下
Jake:这其实就是一个乡下
Shure: 就不是真正的北京
Katrina: 我在北京二环也住过郊区也住过地地道道北京人
Jake:哦
Jake:二环内也挺破
Shure: 你挤过地铁吗
Shure: Have you ever squeezed into the subway?
Katrina: 挤过
Jake:几号线1号线是不是你过来的
Katrina: 我当时我昌平也去过
Katrina: 我当时面北师
Katrina: 北师昌平也去过
Katrina: 然后北航在学院路那边
Katrina:  然后又第三次来的时候去玩天安门
Katrina: 然后环球也玩了
Katrina: 然后颐和园也玩了
Shure: 这离环球近
Shure: 我来
Lucia: 我有个方法，就是离咱人这近的部分擦一下
Lucia: I have an idea, let's just wipe the parts close to us.
Shure:  那吃的不也得放这
Shure: But the food also needs to be placed here.
Lucia: 呃吃的尽量别挨着桌子呗哈哈
Lucia: Uh, try not to put the food near the table, haha.
Katrina: 你更喜欢肯德基还是麦当劳
Shure: 麦当劳啊
Shure: McDonald's.
Lucia: 这个这个这抹布要不咱就放外边用
Lucia: How about we just use this rag outside?
Jake:行再过一点点
Lucia: 然后我看里边还有新的就到时候洗碗还是干啥就用新的
Lucia: And I saw there are new ones inside, so for washing dishes or something, we can use the new ones.
Lucia: 谢谢谢谢辛苦
Lucia: Thank you, thank you, it's hard work.
Lucia: 啊sorry
Lucia: Ah, sorry.
Shure:  那个拿一下
Lucia:但是感觉一个抹布不够用 要是整个整个擦一下的话那我就干脆
Lucia: But it feels like one rag isn't enough. If we wipe everything, then I might as well...
Shure: 先糊弄糊弄得了哪天买个桌布啥的
Shure: 就一次性那种虽然
Shure: 但是他真的很好用不符合我们的理念
Shure: But it's really good to use, even if it doesn't match our philosophy.
Lucia: 因为一个抹布的话
Lucia: Because with just one rag...
Lucia: 感觉可能擦整个擦不太干净所以我本来说
Lucia: It might not be clean enough if we wipe everything, so I was saying...
Lucia: 光把边上大家用到的地方擦一下
Lucia: Let's just wipe the edges where everyone touches.
Lucia: 要不再拿一个
Jake:再拿一个抹布
Katrina:  你不饿了吗
Katrina: Aren't you hungry?
Alice: 你吃吧
Alice: You go ahead and eat.
Tasha: 我不敢吃吧吃吧
Tasha: I don't dare, go ahead, eat.
Tasha: 啊不好意思
Tasha: Ah, sorry.
Shure:  没事我们现在是一个没有什么
Shure: It's okay, we're pretty chill right now.
Alice: 别做啊现在这个脏
Alice: Don't do it, it's dirty now.
Tasha: :为什么6个人只点4杯饮料
Alice: 我不喝哦
Alice: I'm not drinking.
Tasha: 你不喝嗯哎
Tasha: You're not drinking? Hmm, oh.
Alice:我不能喝冰的
Alice: I can't drink cold stuff.
Shure:  谁干的这种事情
Alice:我这几天来大姨妈了喝不了所以我才睡这么死
Alice: It's that time of the month for me, so I can't drink it. That's why I'm so sleepy.
Tasha: 你是这几天
Tasha: Is it these days?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Shure:  吃布洛芬吃的是吗
Shure: Taking ibuprofen, right?
Alice: 今天是疯狂星期四的一半
Alice: Today is the halfway point of Crazy Thursday.
Shure: 今天是Tuesday吗
Shure: Is today Tuesday?
Alice:对Tuesday野餐呢
Alice: Yes, Tuesday picnic.
Shure: 哦锡克内克day
Shure: Oh, Sick Neck Day.
Shure: This is toko Tuesady
Shure: This is Taco Tuesday.
Jake:好心机啊
Jake: So sneaky.
Katrina: 嗯我手机呢
Shure:  为什么你手机放我手上
Shure: Why is your phone in my hand?
Katrina: 我不知道啊哈哈哈哈
Lucia: I don't know, hahaha.
Jake:这还一个旺仔牛奶呢
Tasha: 我喝旺仔牛奶吧
Tasha: I'll drink a Wang Zai milk.
Shure: 好嘞
Jake: 我来我来抱
Jake: I'll do it, I'll hold it.
Lucia: 没事没事
Tasha: 这凳子是不是也得也得  啊小心
Tasha: Should we be careful with the chair too?
Tasha: 为什么不点肯德基的蛋挞
Tasha: Why not order the KFC egg tarts?
Lucia: 让我看看这凳子脏不脏
Lucia: Let me check if this chair is dirty.
Tasha: 哎好吧凳子也挺脏的
Tasha: Oh well, the chair is quite dirty too.
Jake:这个闻所未闻但是可以
Jake: This is unheard of but okay.
Jake:肯德基  烤鸭
Jake: KFC roast duck
Lucia: 那边我把那两个凳子擦一下
Lucia: Let me wipe those two chairs over there.
Jake:肯德基披萨
Jake: KFC pizza
Jake: 笑可以外国人
Jake: Laughing, foreigners
Jake:那他点的肯德基是什么东西
Tasha: 他们的肯德基跟我们不太一样是吧
Tasha: Their KFC is different from ours, right?
Alice: 这是中式的有骨有骨鸭
Alice: This is Chinese-style bone-in duck
Lucia: 对肯德基麦当劳新品好像国内外都不太一样吧
Lucia: Yes, the new items at KFC and McDonald's are different domestically and abroad.
Alice: 有骨鸭米花
Alice: Bone-in duck popcorn
Tasha: 呃口感也不一样
Tasha: Uh, the texture is different too.
Katrina: 夹了那种什么辣的，辣椒酱的那种鸡肉卷
Jake:就是国内的肯德基麦当劳比国外卷多了
Shure: 坐啊
Alice: 中式鸭肉卷笑死
Alice: Chinese-style duck roll, that's funny.
Lucia: 这是土豆泥吗
Lucia: Is this mashed potatoes?
Alice: 哎是不是凳子不太够
Alice: Hey, are there not enough chairs?
Lucia: 正好6个
Lucia: Exactly 6.
Shure: 那边还有一个
Lucia: 但是那边那边的还没来得及没来得及擦啊
Lucia: But those over there haven't been wiped yet.
Alice: 这是没擦吧
Alice: This one isn't wiped, right?
Jake:没擦擦一下
Jake: Wipe it.
Alice: 抹布在哪在这
Alice: Where's the cloth? Here it is.
Lucia: 哦在这
Lucia: 这这4个都擦过了刚才
Lucia: These four have been wiped just now.
Lucia: 那另外的还没来得及擦啊
Lucia: The others haven't been wiped yet.
Alice: 这根本就擦不干净
Alice: This can't be cleaned properly.
Shure: 停了
Shure: 停吗
Jake:呃 停吧 吃汉堡吧那就不拍了
Jake:吃汉堡这个不太重要
Jake:停停停
Katrina: ok
Jake:眼镜我们放进去吧 在这晒坏了